this is Startalk drew Davenport
and drew Davenport is writing from
wilmut Illinois here on planet earth he
actually put it that way oh that's good
yeah
have you ever found anything that you
couldn't identify or thought was really
strange
during a spectral analysis this is for
both of you actually because I'm sure
that spectral analysis is as part of
both your missions Oh major major well
is there anything that comes back were
you just like nah that's that's odd well
I am NOT a spectral analyzer myself but
I remember in the early days of the
Cassini mission when we were looking at
the results of one of the spectrometers
onboard Cassini that had scooped up
material in the plume and there were
some signatures that they couldn't make
sense of and I think at first in fact
they made a tentative identification
which did not turn out to be correct and
it turned out to be salt had they had
not thought that there would be salt and
when they went back and said okay maybe
this is salt and they went back and did
the match it was a great match so that's
my little anecdote Chris you must have
one I can't think think it's something I
can but along the lines that I remember
when we were first going to Titan we
thought it had a global ocean we got
there it didn't so that we were often
surprised I think we have to keep that
in mind we are deaths is of what's out
there are often wrong right the only way
to know is to go look you know this
brings up something that I love to just
remind people of in in being explorers
like we are you know we're kind of our
if not our bodies our minds and our
emotions are on these robotic spacecraft
that we send across the solar system and
you know they find things that are you
know we say oh my god that's so
surprising we felt that way about the
Enceladus plume we felt that way about
the district
lucien of the hydrocarbons on titan we
all felt that way about Pluto when New
Horizons got to Pluto oh my goodness
look at this these regions where you
have ice convection and these polygonal
features it's not so much that it's a
failure of knowledge it's a failure of
imagination
we understand physics pretty well and
chemistry we understand what happens at
various regimes physical regimes but
it's just that we don't spend an
infinite amount of time imagining all
the various permutations we might find
there and when we get there we end up
being surprised like take that and sell
it as geysers we know post voyager this
was after the Voyager mission a couple
of years later a paper was written about
the possibility that we could have water
geysers on Enceladus alright it was
suggested that these geysers they might
not have been called geysers but they
would be producing particles that would
go into orbit around Saturn to produce
the e ring in which Enceladus is
centrally embedded so that was the
connection so we had geysers on the
brain when we went to back to Enceladus
with Cassini and we even the imaging
team planned observations to look for
them and the first image that we have of
a plume coming off Enceladus has the
word plume in the title of the
observation it was deliberately planned
to search for plumes right so we knew
what we might find but nobody took the
time to imagine well okay so we have
geysers coming off in celle dhis the
gravity on Enceladus is only one
hundredth of the gravity here on the
earth so these things are going to be
enormous no one thought that right so we
get they there and we see this
incredible spectacle and it just it it
just reminded me of this that you know
we we always fail to imagine what we
might find so it and it's what it makes
it so thrilling you know just seeing
something for the first time it's just
it's mind-blowing that's pretty cool
you